Sansa Stark the lady of Winterfell. Thank you for inviting us into your home lady Stark
Winterfell is yours your grace
Hi, everyone is Charlie. This is gonna be my Game of Thrones season 8 episode 1 video. Congratulations
You all made it now everybody grab your Valyrian swords and hop a dragon. Let's go
I'll be doing videos all season long. If you're brand new to the channel. Be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
I also do a weekly HBO now giveaway
All you have to do to enter that is be a subscriber and leave a comment on the video
There was so much stuff in the episode to cover so many Easter eggs and references to earlier
Episodes particularly the pilot episode that I did this like a top 15 instead of my normal top 10
Careful for spoilers if you have not seen the episode yet. So starting with number 15 the brand new intro sequence
they got a major upgrade to not only the map table that it pans around but also the
Astrolabe itself you notice that the emblems aren't only just the house sigils
They also tell the story of A Song of Ice and Fire
they even referenced the Dragons in the comet from way back in season 1 if you ever wondered whether or not they would reference the
Comet again
You also probably picked up on the fact that the intro sequence
begins from the knight Kings
Perspective because you start facing south you crush through the wall is the camera pans around you notice the deep blue tiles flipping over on
The regular winter tiles just denoting their paths as they come straight down to the last hearth
So the map table itself is telling you where the night king is going
It's basically telling you the story of the show episode by episode like they came down to the last part first
Then they're turning to Winterfell the other important thing, too
Is that when they take you through each of the bigger locations like Winterfell and King's Landing you actually go inside the buildings
They particularly
Denote places like the crypts because that's where Jon Snow finds the truth about his parents when you're in King's Landing
They also remind you about the scorpion that's pointing at balerion the black dread skull
Underneath the throne room
just because there's gonna be a big threat to Daenerys his dragons this season because Cersei is still on the opposite side of this I
Don't know how effective it'd be against vissarion's since technically he's still dead
I suppose you could do enough damage to his wings with enough scorpion bolts that you could probably bring him down that way 14
Jon Snow and Daenerys arrived at Winterfell
So if you couldn't tell this is a giant homage to the pilot episode when Robert Baratheon arrived they even had the same
Soundtrack when they were marching in the name of the song is the King arrives
So they also do a mirror scene, you know if you remember the pilot
So you see Aria running through the crowd she jumps up on top of that wagon to get a good vantage point
But this time it's another northerner a little boy whose perspective you're getting is he sort of runs through the crowd he rushes past
Aria who smiles at him because she's taller now
They make a joke about her being taller later in the episode so she can see just fine
He climbs on top of a branch just like bran climbed on top of the castle to get a better
look
It's a progression of Aria smiles as people went by she got really
Excited when Jon Snow went by like she wanted to call out to him
But she wasn't quite sure so she let him pass but then she saw the Hound in Gendry smiled even bigger
She gave the biggest reaction when the dragons flew overhead though. Just that look of wonder blooming on her face
That was the one that they put in the teaser that we kept seeing earlier this year
The look on Santa's face when the dragons fly overhead looks more like worry, but we all know about the Sansa Daenerys drama
That's gonna be happening the first couple of episodes
So it just sort of laying the seeds for that like she's worried about Daenerys and what's going to happen with her being up there
Thirteen, Jon Snow introduces Daenerys to the stark family in the northern Lords
So there's a couple awkward moments a couple funny moments just like Robert Baratheon greeting all the Starks. So John just rushes to hug
Bran, because they haven't seen each other since season one
Sansa is happy to see him again, but then it gets really awkward once Daenerys walks out
That was the shot in the trailer that we kept seeing your grace Winterfell is yours and here's all the shade in the world
But if you look in the background of these shots even funnier is the little bear who's staring daggers next to yon
Royce I feel like the way they played the brand reveal telling Daenerys about
Viserion being an undead white at the command of the night
King was played as a little bit of a dark joke to just cut the tension
We don't have time for this
I need to tell you about all the terrible things that happened to your child and they do it again later in the episode when?
Daenerys is talking to Sam. Well, a lot of really dark but funny moments at the same time
You feel kind of bad for laughing at them particularly when Samwell is finding out about his family dying
But things only continue to get more awkward towards the end of the episode
They just want to set up the drama plot for the next couple of episodes so number twelve
Jon Snow versus the little bear and the rest of the northern Lords, they don't waste any time and digging into him
So this is all about setting up the idea that they started last season where the northern Lords got really pissed at Jon for leaving
And now they're even more upset because he bent the knee and he's no longer technically king in the north
there was even the funny joke about little Lord umber not being sure what the power structure was because
Has so many people at the front of the table
He said milady to Santa then milord to Jon Snow then your grace to Daenerys
That was obviously just to remind you that he was a character on the show so that the reveal at the end of the episode
When the night King used him for finger paints was that much more shocking 11 was the Tyrion and Sansa reunion
I felt so bad about Tyrion in this episode. They are really laying it on thick
I used to think that you were the cleverest man alive. This is sort of like the beginning of the end for Tyrion
Say your prayers if you thought that he made bad decisions during season seven all the times in the episode that he assured
Everyone including the northern Lords in front of everyone that Cersei was definitely going to be sending them reinforcements is not gonna bode
well
when Jaime arrives and tries to
Explain to them what's really going on. They have a couple more of those really dark funny moments joking about Joffrey's wedding
Oh, it had its moments. Like Sansa was really happy that he died, but you kind of bolted. Well we both survived
Congratulations, I think a lot of this isn't so much about making Sansa seem smarter
I think it's more about making Tyrion seem like he's slowly falling from grace
Just like making one bad call after another that really ominous
Look that brand gives him at the end of the episode does not bode well for Tyrion, so just say your prayers
But number 10 Jon Snow re reunion in the godswood
you used to be taller like making another joke about re being super tall and not needing to climb up on that wagon like she
Did during the pilot they make a couple references to her being a faceless person. How did you sneak up on me?
How did you survive a knife to the heart?
Probably one of the funniest Jon Snow jokes that he's ever told I didn't survive
So never let it be said that Jon Snow could never tell a joke as his his sense of humor is very Ned Stark
They have a nice embrace referencing a moment from season 1 episode 2 when he gave her a needle
You used it a couple times another joke
Yeah
Used it a couple then several times after that us remembering all the people that she's killed the weird thing about the long Claud moment
Though is that I don't know what kind of payoff they were trying to give because she has the dagger
She didn't tell him about it. Are you jealous that I have this giant Valyrian sword?
It seems a little weird that she wouldn't have wit the dagger out and shown him in that moment all the talk about
Arya taking Sansa side in all these arguments is just paying off that art from last season
The lone wolf dies, but the pack survives. That was what that Littlefinger plot was all about
So one that lets you know that there's not going to be any kind of drama between Arya and Sansa this season
But it all leads into that quote where John says just remind her that I'm her family, too
and Aria says don't you forget that either because he's getting ready to find out whose parents truly are so he's gonna be
Conflicted about his family, but the stark family will still treat him like family ari is just trying to remind him of that
So this is all set up for that big payoff at the end of the episode number nine
the golden company arrives at King's Landing
This is also one of those really dark and funny moments because Cersei he's got this weird smile on her face
Like she's very smug Qyburn runs out to tell her your grace
It's terrible the dead have breached the wall and all she can say is good
That's great and walks back in to receive the golden company
They lay a little bit of groundwork in their
Conversation for a year on versus everyone else type of conflict where you find out that he probably killed a couple members of the golden
Company says, oh, you know they weren't good warriors. You won't miss them. They were cheating at games, or maybe I was cheating
I don't remember so it definitely sounds like he killed him and Harry Strickland. Is it really happy about it?
But he's putting up with it because Cersei is paying them so much money
So obviously I've already done a couple videos about the golden company their background
I'm hoping for a couple really big moments from them this season a couple big battles
But I don't know how big they're gonna be and how much of their history they're gonna get into if they're any big Easter eggs
And videos or scenes then I'll let you guys know, but for now, they're just sort of laying a little bit of groundwork
Although they do have a joke about elephants
And I wonder if that was because the production the producers didn't want to deal with the hassle of filming with elephants
So she had a couple lines of dialogue that felt like they were very meta jokes from the writers
Just talking to the fans like we really really wanted to see some elephants
But we couldn't afford it and it's too difficult to deal with when you're trying to film a big battle scene
So I don't know whether or not we're actually gonna see elephants this season or if they'll pay that off later
But number eight then you have the Cersei vs
Euron subplot with him trying to bed her to make good on their agreement worse. Take a long time
Why don't we just get this over with right now?
And there's this weird look on her face like you wonder what her thought process is like is she just trying to keep him under?
Her thumb is she worried that he's going to propel against her because she definitely hates him
Do you want to keep your head attached to your body?
And then after he leaves it almost seems like she's gonna throw up in her wine glass
She definitely hates Iran and is trying to outmaneuver him, but number seven, welcome back
Bran, who is now officially teamed Cersei? Although he does look conflicted about it. He really wants that castle
I think that's the justification for character standpoint. Love it or hate it
I do love that funny conversation that he has with the girls in his bed
I'm one of the only people that's ever brought down a dragon. That's a big deal
Like he's trying to remind them about how he's an important person the comedic timing of this scene with Qyburn is almost perfect though
I think that was more to pay off the
WTF moment at the end when he found out exactly what Cersei wanted him to do, but is the young woman?
Propositions Qyburn, you know, I'm very fond of old men and he says oh poor girl
She's gonna die of pox within the year and bronto most chokes on his wine. Which girl are you talking about?
Then Qyburn explains that should Jaime and Tyrion survive the war with the dead Cersei wants Bronn to kill them in poetic justice
Wants him to do it using the crossbow the Tyrion used to kill Tywin during season 4
This is the same crossbow that he used against him
So I think this is just the beginning of a bunch of main characters making really good or really terrible choices
And they're not leading to their eventual demise. So if you notice characters making morally reprehensible
Decisions during episodes. It probably means they're headed for some big come up
And so something terrible might wind up happening to Bronn 6 Fionna and his Ironborn rescue Yara off a Hurons boat
I love the way that she just head-butted him
that was for being so weak and not being able to rescue her and stand up to your on back during season 7 remember he
Just stood there and pissed himself when you're on challenge him. Come over here take her from me now
He seems a little more sure of himself
Then he splits with her to go back to Winterfell to fight the army of the Dead and be more honorable
She goes back to the Iron Islands to try and take them because they aren't being defended by Euron at the moment
Maybe Theon will make it there before the big episode 3 battle
But number 5 Jon Snow finally rides ragle for the first time. He rides a dragon one of the biggest questions
That fans have had ever since we learned that he was a secret Targaryen even before that when people suspected it
But it hadn't been proven yet the funny thing about this too
Is that Ragle even cuddles up to him like a puppy?
Before they begin and they kind of play it for comedy with him flying all over the dragon
but he seems like a natural in the place where they land is a huge call back to Ygritte and Jon Snow's cave they even
Give Daenerys a couple lines of dialogue very similar to what Ygritte said to John Snow while they were still in the cave
Don't go. Let's stay in this cave forever. Dinner says we could stay in here for a thousand years and even funnier - was dragons
To their public display of affection, but he's just being protective but Johnson
Oh just that look of terror on his face as drogon gets really protective of her for was Gendry aria and the hounds reunion
now obviously she has very different types of relationships with both of those people like the Hound was being a little more grew up with
Her you seem like a cold bitch, but I suppose that's why you're still alive
That's his way of telling her that he's happy to see her
I'm happy that you're still alive
The Gendry reunion also had a couple lines of dialogue
referencing moments that they had together back during season 3 where she said you could be my family and he says no you would be
My ladies, so he calls her my lady couple times
She finally smiles
But they also lay the seeds for the special weapon quote-unquote that he's going to be creating for her using her Valyrian dagger
So it's just a really large spirit you saw during the trailer when she's spinning it around in that huge battle
So it's just gonna be a really cool badass weapon and he gave the hounds the big upgrade of the dragon glass axe
3 was Daenerys his conversation with Samwell that went off the rails so quickly in the most
Wonderful way possible the whole reason. She sought him out was to thank him for curing Serge. Auras. Greyscale during season 7
she makes it sound like she's going to reinstate him as a student in the citadel or even name him as a full-blown maester just
something really wonderful
He's really excited and they start talking about Valyrian swords
And that's how they get to her burning his family their timing during this was perfect
But you kind of feel bad for chuckling a little bit. So he says well my father's dead. That's awful
But at least my brothers still alive, I'll get to go home and she's like, no can't do that. I burned your brother, too
That's when he loses it, but look at the nurse's reaction
She is stone cold as if she'd do it again in a heartbeat
if she had to the look on Sir George face in the background while this is happening is
priceless - but this sort of leads Samwell to talk to bran in the r + l equals j so number - Samwell finally tells
John the truth about R + L equals J. You were never a bastard
So John is at Ned Stark statue trying to make sense of everything and Sam confronts him about the death of his family
And they try to play it as if they're
Questioning Daenerys his honor also - when he tells him the truth about being the true heir to the Iron Throne
Daenerys didn't tell you the truth about what she did to my family. Isn't that interesting
Would Daenerys also set aside her claim to the throne?
The way that you set aside your crown to bend the knee and save your people by forming this alliance in the first place
It's all just drama that they're building towards in episode 2 in the eventual at three big battle
The rest of the episode is really just a parade of horror like reactions that different characters have to different situations Jaime arriving at Winterfell
satisfied with himself
I'm doing the honorable thing
But then immediately noticing brand in recognizing him the look of horror and remorse on his face is priceless
but number one we have to talk about that genuine horror moment with the Nights Watch at the last heart to the end of the
Episode turns out they didn't get those extra wagons and horses quite as quickly as they needed
So torment and barrack have made it down from the wall with a couple of the wildlings
They run into EDD in the Nights Watch who are also
Investigating the last hearts and they find little Lord umber who's been turned into finger paints by the night king who does not go quickly
Like they try to set him on fire and he just continues screaming and screaming they just draw the scene right out
It's a really genuine classic horror moment from Game of Thrones. We don't get those very often. But because this is the final season
I'm expecting a little bit more of this. I did like the joke about torment always having blue eyes
Just another one of those weird comedic moments. They worked into the episode, but let me know in the comments
What was your favorite moment or your biggest WTF?
What will happen is is I will do a trailer video for episode two tomorrow and I'll name a giveaway winner during that
I'm also doing Q&A videos. That'll probably be on Tuesday
So leave all the questions in the comments that you want me to include in that or any just big things that you were confused
About during the episode
While you wait for everything click here for all my Game of Thrones
Season 8 trailer and promo videos and click here to learn a little bit more about what's going on with the night came this season
Thank you so much for watching. Everybody. Stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight